I'm wearing an all denim jumpsuit I
don't even know what level I'm on for
you to get on hi it's me
grace Helbig that person that you should
definitely be subscribed to because
she's really close to 3 million
subscribers and would feel a real sense
of pride and accomplishment if she got
there or you don't have to because now
your responsibility to make me happy
it's my responsibility to make you happy
YouTube there's no Priory today because
I didn't video things this week but I'm
doing it now though better late than
pregnant ancient Chinese proverb I
didn't film anything this week again
because I just I think I'm taking a
break from vlogging in that way I'm
prepping because I'm gonna be vlogging
and snapchatting a ton while I'm on book
tour which I leave for tomorrow because
the book comes out February 2nd so go to
grey style book calm and pre-order the
book and see where I'm stopping on my
book tour and if you're able to come
hang out with me and get a signed book
and feel things but don't worry I have a
great idea for an excellent video that
will definitely help you procrastinate
the way Friday area was supposed to I'm
going to show you how you can have the
perfect Valentine's Day date using a
scene on TV products you've probably
seen a lot of other youtubers use these
products and videos before but I haven't
done it yet and you know what they say
if all of your friends jump off a bridge
you definitely jump off the bridge with
them like what if that bridge catches on
fire and they're all saved and then you
die in the fire like you look like an
idiot
what's the first thing you could do in
preparation for a Valentine's Day date
make yourself beautiful hide all the
terrible aka put on some secret color
this is colorful hair that you can clip
into your real hair I don't think it's
gonna be a secret oh these are by Demi
Lovato look there she is
boy ahh I live my life in color because
I'm a human and not a dog new it's color
without the commitment that's what I
said that one time I did that porn with
that black guy available for Demi
inspired colors pink red purple blue
those don't sound very inspired those
sound like straight-up colors but if
Demi is responsible for inspiring the
read that Wow before frumpy dumpy after
Wow should take a [ __ ] on my chest
that's a hot cheese yep this is how you
open boxes right yes it's like an elf
foot how to directions these seem like a
lot of pain directions whoo headband
that's got hair on it eyes are a big
black thing that was a quote from the
porno that I did with that black man oh
wow okay be right back and we're gonna
be beautiful
yeah I should have read the directions
then Wow turns out my real hair is worse
than this Demi Lovato hair oh there we
go
Wow I did it way wrong grace did you do
something to your hair it's a secret
this is definitely a secret very subtle
this isn't ombre this is um bra I don't
hate it though it just blends so
naturally like Donald Trump and the
human condition okay now that we're
looking beautiful on to the next step
you have to on Valentine's Day get your
date a gift engrave it pro BAM I'm gonna
engrave a munching love something onto
some hard surface engrave it and save it
that is this generation set it and
forget it
includes bonus three stencils and a
bonus replacement tip I've got a boner
engrave anything I don't think that's
what you mean what am I gonna engrave I
should have gotten that part let's find
something I found a butter knife I'm
like the best date ever
the tip will not even puncture a balloon
what about a scrotum the balloon of the
body instruction surprisingly less
instructions than the secret hair wires
two double-a batteries no this is like
when you find out of the guy that you're
on a date with has a wife and you're
like you should wear a sign don't leave
this out especially if it's dark and
you're horny is am i doing it oh yeah
hey
and then we just hit this I think we're
doing it
whoa it's working oh boy it's very
difficult to do Wow oh my god ah thank
God I don't give tattoos literally oh
boy shup oh my god that one got away
from me alright well that kind of work
look I can't stab loving you cuz it's
the knife
wow this Valentine's Day dates going
great what's the next thing that you
need on a Valentine's date food
obviously you know what I think of when
I think of romance eggs we've got the
eggstractor and we are going to extract
a hard-boiled egg from a chill
I made hard-boiled eggs for the sake of
this video please subscribe
eggs let's get this eggstractor out I
guess I'm an eggstractor tractor we
should date we're both tools whoa just
said stop all over it before using
please read instruction manual there's a
lot of like warnings on this why
important read before use look I know
the struggle of really wanting the
public to read something that you've
written grace style book calm oh good
there's pictures alright let's do what
happen there's I'm going to do I'm going
to try and make it in so we got tap this
buddy on this that seems like I did
something and then this goes here whoa
this is very athletic and then this goes
on top and then you just go boom right
just want you to know that's been the
best date of my life get the egg out
there is no egg dad got stuck it happens
to a lot of extractors don't worry keep
the egg Kimmy day please give me the egg
oh my god I should have read the
instructions I'm sorry Oh smells like
eggs
well how romantic crack the large and by
tapping wait you're just cracking this
egg completely open and then okay okay
look I'm tapping the egg all around
everywhere so like me just so cracked so
broken one two three right
okay damn it give me the egg oh no
something more rewarding about just
peeling the egg yourself
this is about rude great day if this
isn't safe best Valentine's Day day ever
I don't know what does if you haven't
already I would love for you to preorder
my style book Grace and style the art of
pretending you have it at grace style
book calm comes out on February 2nd and
I'm really really proud of it this is
what an author looks like I don't know
the egg was good and then it really got
bad real fast